I'm to learn about
economics and to understand,
you know,
the source of the problems because
anybody could just blame it on some rich
person who's hoarding money and
discriminating against them.
They love doing that. And then
just say, oh, this solution.
See if you blame the problems on some
rich person. Well the solution is easy.
Just take his money, right,
have the government come in and,
and redistribute the wealth. The
W, which is another word for steel.
Take money from somebody who earned
it and give it to somebody who didn't.
But if you actually take a little bit of
time and use your head instead of your,
your, your, your, your heart, your
feelings, uh, you'll learn that you know,
that the source of the problems is
government interference in the economy and
that the protest should
be directed at government,
at their regulations and their subsidies
and their taxes and all of the things
that government does to stifle economic
growth and deny opportunities to people.
D W I think there would be a really
funny documentary if you could do like a
documentary on the last occupier,
like the last person to occupy Wall Street
because it had to be like stragglers,
right. Eventually must've gotten to the
point where there's like 30 people left,
20 people left,
they one guy now fuck these people man.
You know, they started occupying
different areas, right?
Cause it caught on and it was all over
the world they were occupying here and
occupying their, and they
were setting up camps. Right.
They're essentially
living there. Yeah. Yeah.
And who knows what else they
were doing there. But um,
but now the occupied more a movement
kind of morphed into the Bernie Sanders
Movement, right? Because that's
where all those guys are now.
They were volunteering for
the Sanders campaign and,
and socialism is really kind of going
mainstream now because they put the word
Democrat in front of it as if somehow
that changes the meeting. Right.
I'm not a socialist.
I'm a democratic socialist.
Meaning I want to vote for socialism
as opposed to just have, you know,
an armed revolution. But the
end is still the same. Right?
It's still a socialism and
it's, it doesn't work. Yeah.
It was watching an interview
with Tucker Carlson
and some guy's a professor
at Harvard and uh, he said,
I'll give you the last word. He guys said,
socialism is going to win. Thank you.
I made the piece. I'm like, what
is that? What does that even mean?
Like socialism is going to
win. What is it? What does
that mean? What is socialism?
Well, it could win at
the polls. That's the
problem. It's very intoxicating to
people who don't know any better. Right?
And the interesting thing,
people, they have too much money.
The interesting thing about socialism is
that no matter how many times it fails,
people expect it to succeed, right?
That's the definition of insanity, right?
Doing something over and over again
and expecting a different result. Well,
the Socialists always expect a different
result from doing something that has
never succeeded in the past.
Socialism by definition is one thing,
but by the emotional reaction to
people have is kind of another thing.
The emotional reaction is there's
rich people that are a real problem.
They're hoarding their greedy. I'm
not concerned with money. I want,
I'm concerned with people and community
and feelings and health and welfare and
education and all that money.
We should take it from those rich people
and we should funnel it into education
and community. And they say
all these words that make
people feel good. Like, yeah,
we're not about money either.
It's all, it's all about feeling good.
That's what the liberals are about.
It's about,
you know,
feeling that they're better than
everybody else because they're, you know,
they're,
they're higher up on this moral pedestal
because they don't care about money.
They just care about, you
know, people and you know.
But when you talk about rich people,
they don't hoard money. I mean,
the way you get rich is not by hoarding.
The way you get rich is by trying to
figure out what problems people have that
you can solve,
right?
Whether it's inventing something that
makes their lives better or providing a
service that makes their lives better
because the customers are in charge
individuals, right? That that's what's
going to allocate wealth. It's if,
if somebody is better than somebody else
at satisfying the desires that people
have, right? If, if I can come
up with something that you like,
that you want to buy that's cheaper and
better than what somebody else has come
up with,
then you're going to buy from me.
And so the person who ends up with the
most money is the person who's satisfied,
the most desires, the most needs in
the most efficient way possible. And,
and that's what's benefiting society.
I mean,
it's great to have charity and
I'm all for private charity,
but if you look at the
wealthiest men in history,
even though they've been
incredible philanthropist
and they've given away a lot
of money,
they helped a lot more people,
a massing their fortunes
than gifting away.
What they made it was the businesses
that they created, the, the,
the products that they invented,
the services that they provided
and the employment, right?
That was all a function of
they're creating their wealth.
That's what did a lot more to help society
than simply giving away some of the
money that they earned. Have you ever
had a debate with a democratic socialist?
Well, I mean, most
Democrats are socialists.
They just don't know it or
they don't want to admit it.
I and a lot of people
don't even understand what
socialism is because you know
you'll have the left. I'll always
consider somebody like even Donald Trump,
they'll say, oh, he's a fascist, right?
They don't even realize that
fascism is part of socialism.
Socialism is a broad concept that includes
things like Communism and fascism.
So if you're a communist,
you are a socialist. But by,
but it doesn't mean that
if you're a socialist,
you're a communist because
you could be a fascist,
you could be for a lot of things,
but fascism is a form of socialism where
the government doesn't just steal all
the property,
like the communist want to nationalize
everything and take legal ownership of
the means of production.
Right? The government just
owns all the capital under.
Under fascism,
the government is a little bit smarter.
They realize that people will work
harder if they think they're working for
themselves. So the fastest doesn't
want to nationalize businesses.
They just want to control it
through regulation and taxes.
And that's pretty much what
the Democrats want to do.
They want to control everything by
taxing it heavily and regulating it.
And those, that's an important
aspect of fascist. I mean,
a lot of people associate fascism with
racism just because the Nazis were,
were racist, but you don't
have to be racist. I mean,
fascism started in Italy and that
there wasn't any racism there.
And if you go back to, uh, the Nazi party,
it's the National Socialist Party of
Germany. That's what the Nazis are.
It's socialists.
So fascism is a form of socialism.
That's why the communists
and the fascists, you know,
argue so much because they're really,
they're fighting over the same turf.
It's which brand of socialism is better,
fascism or communism,
but they're not at opposite
ends of the political spectrum.
They're on the same end.